you
it started if everyone could start
coming back in
I'm on the far side here on the
good afternoon everyone we're gonna get
started again after our afternoon break
so please come on back in I have the
distinct pleasure this afternoon to
introduce a panel of very very
distinguished guests my name is Anna
Steve Caen I have met some of you before
during the course of today and the
associate director for innovation and
strategic partnerships with the Scott
Institute for energy innovation at
Carnegie Mellon quite a mouthful it's a
great job and an opportunity to meet all
of you so I work day in and day out to
bring together partnerships and and
create synergies where possibly they did
not exist before and so as a part of
that we have brought together this very
esteemed panel on public-private
partnerships activating city utility and
university engagement so today I welcome
to the stage grant Irvin who's the chief
resilience officer an assistant director
for the Department of City Planning city
of Pittsburgh at the far end he's our
moderator today so grant serves as the
chief resilience officer where he
oversees the integration of
sustainability and resilience into city
services programs and policy and is a
great partner to Carnegie Mellon
University Jason Anderson is in the
middle he's the president and CEO of
clean tech San Diego which is a
nonprofit organization for members which
includes more than 100 local businesses
universities government and nonprofits
committed to advancing sustainable
solutions for the benefit of the economy
in the environment as president and CEO
Jason manages manages and leads several
initiatives including smart cities San
Diego advocacy efforts and economic
development programs Phillip Macy is
further down in the middle he is the
president and CEO of Itron he is an
industry visionary working to drive
digital transformation in the utility
space during his tenure at Itron the
company has grown from a metering
technology provider to a leader in the
Internet of Things connecting smart
devices to me
to better manage resources Itron is a
leader in the energy and water sectors
and maisy helps drive the dialogue
around utilizing technology and data to
create more connected vibrant efficient
and safer utilities and cities David
Owens joins us as well
he is the retired executive vice
president of Edison Electric Institute
he's an accomplished executive with
extensive experience in public policies
surrounding utility operations strategic
planning technology development rate
making and regulation he retired from EE
I last year but he remains an advisor to
EE I and serves on the board of Xcel
Energy he also chairs the transformation
Advisory Council providing insights in
the new design of the Puerto Rico
electric systems from what I understand
he has hardly retired at all
and finally we have rich rios e
president and CEO of Duquesne Light
Company here in Pittsburgh he serves as
the president and chief executive
officer in Duquesne Light and Duquesne
Light Company and the holding companies
under Ari Aziz leadership the company
invested significant resources to ensure
that its infrastructure the wires
substation poles and other equipment
that make the company's transmission and
distribution system meets current and
future electric demands and with that
I'm going to turn it over to you grant
and our esteemed panel great thank you
Anna and thank you all for for joining
us here this afternoon for this really
great panel and thank you all gentlemen
for coming to Pittsburgh the three of
you and rich rich is the he's the
hometown entertainment here so so it's
great to spend a you know spend an
afternoon with you guys and talking
about some really innovative things just
a little bit of context I guess for why
this panel and
and I have the pleasure of hosting a
class this semester here at Carnegie
Mellon on kind of exactly this topic
really looking at the issues of smart
cities and the integration of smart city
data and utilities and when we started
to conceptualize this I think one of the
things that really became one of the
hallmarks of the conversation was the
need for partnerships and the need for
dialogue and as I just you know kind of
look down the line and one of the things
is I've had the pleasure of meeting each
of these individuals and having kind of
an opportunity to share space and time
with them and either on different panels
or just using kind of your guidance and
some of the work that we are doing here
in the city of Pittsburgh and and it
really starts me off kind of the the
first question that I wanted to kind of
ask everyone is you know you're seeing a
lot of synergies right now in this space
between cities and utilities and
universities and and the reason I think
is because there's there's big
challenges that are out there that all
of our our respective sectors are
encountering whether it's issues of
climate change or managing product loss
or integrating technology into our
business platforms we're confronting the
same questions at the same time but
maybe starting with you Philip in terms
of kind of what you're seeing in terms
of you know Itron and kind of the work
that you guys do around the world kind
of nationally globally why are these
synergies occurring between universities
and private sector partners like
utilities and and cities like what is
the confluence and what's leading to
that well I mean for years people been
talking about the proliferation of
sensors and the proliferation of data
that's generated by those sensors what
we don't talk about as much as is that
there's a lot of work that needs to go
into building economical reliable
accurate sensing devices out in the
field so there's there's continued
research required in order to do that
how we connect those sensors back to the
home office how we operate those
networks and for goodness sake what do
we do with all the data that we're
collecting through these networks are
just these pressing problems where we're
sort of making it up as we go along
and and requires a lot of collaborative
work and collaborative thinking
particularly with universities building
these kinds of data at large data
networks and data analytics capability
requires significant investment and the
idea that there is a complete overlap
and in building infrastructure out
across municipalities primarily for us
water utilities electric and gas
utilities doesn't seem particularly
resourceful or practical to have this
sort of duplication and overlap so we
spend a lot of time working with
multiple stakeholders and in urban
environments really trying to explore
how it is that we can better share
Network resources and and collaborate
more effectively on driving more value
out of data which requires really this
kind of collaborative environment we're
talking about Thank You grant you know
from San Diego's perspective and apology
for being the Californian in the room
and also the purveyor of fine sauce
there you go so from San Diego's
perspective you know we're a we're kind
of the coldest sac of California we're
at the bottom of the state we're
surrounded by the ocean in the desert in
another country and so for us you know
the collaboration is really just kind of
built into our culture it's just a way
we do things in San Diego and when clean
tech San Diego was launched eleven years
ago it was really that mindset around
how do we bring the academic
universities institutions to the table
with the private sector the public
agencies and our one we have one IOU San
Diego Gas and Electric in our region to
really think about these kind of
solutions these problems from a regional
perspective where we all have kind of a
stake in the game for us and we now
start thinking about data and how you
know that this kind of collaboration
around data comes together I know
someone in the previous panel talked
about the the pilot project in Atlanta
around streetlights and sensors we're
doing the same thing in San Diego we've
got 3,400 sensors that are being
installed in our community on street
lights by current and AT&T and that's
pushing out an amazing amount of data
that again we have really no idea what
to do with but what everyone cares in
this collaboration is
economic development how are we creating
jobs how are we benefiting our local
economy what's the result to our local
environment or global environment and so
all this data is turned into just a
really interesting set of tools that app
developers are using to develop
applications and those are creating jobs
and it's just this kind of interesting
kind of confluence of all these
different interested parties so for us
you know we're all coming together in
San Diego because we believe there are
significant climate opportunities cloud
challenges that we need to that we're
facing and we believe that technology
plays a significant role in addressing
those but there's a huge economic
opportunity for that as well so as we
really think about data and pushing data
out into the community the city of San
Diego has an open data portal it's
really about who's gonna take that data
and do what with it and create a next
you know the next economic engine for
San Diego let me respond let me respond
differently to the question an excellent
question I do agree with my colleagues
there responds let's take an example of
what's happening in the electric
industry so right now we have 75 million
smart meters that have been installed
throughout the utility systems in
America we have 220 million customers
that the private sector serves so
tremendous number of customers have
smart meters so smart meters have a mi
so that means that there's data that
comes from those smart meters that can
help that utility plan and understand
when a customer loses service some
customers particularly in San Diego and
other sunny areas have rooftop solar
those ripped-off Soler's have smart
inverters those smart inverters provide
a lot of information about the customers
behavior so does a smart meter some of
those customers in San Diego also have
electric vehicles those electric
vehicles have charging stations that
provide a lot of information all of
these technologies provide tremendous
data that could be very helpful to the
utility as it seeks to play
an operated system universities a part
of that customer base that the utility
serves so one good example would be if I
looked at what's occurring and actually
Phil is doing it in Spokane Washington
where they're working with the
universities where the universities are
taking the viewpoint we have three
objectives that we want to accomplish
much like the utility has these same
objectives we want reliability we want
efficiency or affordability and we want
to improve sustainability so those are
the three areas that are driving a lot
of the need to collaborate and to use
this data in a very useful way right now
the data is very unstructured we get
reams of data as a utility but we don't
structure that data I haven't even
spoken about monitors and sensors that
are throughout the utility system as we
begin to convert our substation so those
substations are much smarter more
analytic and more data-driven so we're
moving into a society where technology
is producing data and we need to have a
way that we are able to structure that
data and make that data much more useful
that's why collaboration is essential so
I'll approach it a little bit
differently being a privately held
company we have investors that expect to
return on our investment and I think you
know we have to overcome some of the
business challenges and how did we
develop a sustainable model at the end
of the day I think you know this unique
time that we live in and these
partnerships that are coming together
are one being driven by a common vision
right that vision that we have to work
and live much more sustainably than we
have have in the past - I think you
heard some of the other earlier panel
speakers talk about the g2 accelerate
this we have some inertia ahead of us
because the economics aren't always
there so how do you overcome that
inertia the unique partnerships that
we're talking about I think afford us
the opportunity to do that so as we
think about smart cities we think that
they're underpinned by three pillars the
first pillar is you
the cost-effectively deploy all the
sensors that are out in the field to
gather that data the second pillar then
is you have to develop a communication
network so you can collect all that data
and move it up to the cloud the third
pillar then is that you have open access
of that data so that we can take the
folks that have the intellectual
capability at the universities that have
a forward lean on that technology and
forward thinking that develop the tools
that we need so that we can operate and
take that data and make effective
economic use out of it so having said
that then when you look at the
partnerships that are evolving between
universities between utilities between
cities we all have assets in the field
the city is a big consumer of some of
the information that will come out of
this to help them operate more
efficiently as a utility we're a
platform operator so we have lots of
sensors in the field today we have
controls in the field to manage you hear
about that a little bit later from some
of the other panel participants so we
have that expertise it's there we've
developed communication networks to
gather all of that data so as what said
here you don't want to replicate those
investments over and over you want to
leverage the assets between all the
players that are at the table so we need
to leverage and contribute our our
infrastructure assets and our knowledge
to the table we partner with the
universities to tap into that
intellectual base we tap into the city
to interface with them and provide you
know products and services to them as
well so I want to jump right off of one
of the things that you just said when
you were talking about leveraging assets
because one of the things that we've
done with the class this semester and
many of the students are here with us
today so there I'm sure going to be
going to be listening very carefully and
intently hi is that we do have an
opportunity particularly in a city that
is rebuilding as we are or at a point of
infrastructure improvement should really
take that opportunity to capitalize
across utilities and so that's really
what we're thinking about as a part of
the class is how can we actually create
an ROI what makes sense for each
individual player within a city to make
those investments investments and and
investigate that data together so that's
really sort of what we've been looking
at you know maybe to pick up on that I
was gonna ask you guys I'm gonna throw a
curveball at you and start with Anna you
know one of the things that we talked
about in preparing for this was you know
what are some of the hallmarks of a
strong partnership so that's the easy
question but like you know through the
class and some of the things that we've
discovered what are some of the
challenges that we're seeing or that
you're experiencing in developing
partnerships what are some of the
pitfalls or some of the the the things
that we might not if we were just here
by ourselves say that we would talk to
and how do you overcome those challenges
in partnership building well an
interesting thing that we've talked
about is data because data is so
important for informed decision making
and yet access to some of that data for
a university partner can be challenging
there's so many privacy rules there's
PUC regulations etc so being able to
access that information to make those
decisions is a critically important part
and I'm just going to use that as my
number one talking point I totally agree
with you and I think I thought did an
outstanding job this morning her
presentation and she made the point that
a utility traditionally is subject to
public policy and that public policy for
the most part is regulation so when
you're engaged in a partnership where
you are heavily regulated and may be
precluded from actually being a total
participant in a project and your
potential partner does not have that
regulatory overlay it creates a
different type of a relationship and I
give it get more explicit so for example
and spoke to the notion of a micro grid
a micro grid is a mini network which has
a power supply source and most of those
power supply sources today or renewable
technologies backed up with batteries
well a utility if you're in at what we
call an organized market if you're in
the Pennsylvania New Jersey Maryland
interconnection or in New York or in
California and in other states you are
precluded from owning power supply you
were told to diverse a power supply to
create a competitive mark
now if you're trying to be a partner
with someone who wants to build a micro
grin you have the balance sheet that can
sustain building that micro grid and you
want to keep that customer and
demonstrate to that customer your
commitment to resiliency you are
precluded for the level of participation
you can have in a micro grid and I know
that as a fact because I've testified in
many of these proceedings so what we
need to do is extend that partnership in
a way where our partner in the micro
grid is able to demonstrate the value
that I bring as a utility to helping
them get that micro grid constructed
that's one example take another example
charging stations in many states a
utility is precluded from owning and
building charging infrastructure so if
you want to enhance EB penetration you
certainly need to have charging stations
it makes a lot of sense to me to have
the utility be a partner in building two
charging stations so we figured out a
way to get into this we said let's do
pilots let's demonstrate that we add
value and the concerns and others have
about our participation do not outweigh
the benefits that we bring to the table
those are just several examples of how
partnerships can be helpful but the
utilities participation those
partnerships can be constrained by the
regulatory process do you have to start
to bring the regulator's in as part of
the partnership is that one of the one
of the ways that we overcome I mean kind
of what you're leading to David is that
we have all this technology out there
but the rules of the game are creating
an impediment for us to make that
penetration into the market I mean how
are you guys starting to find ways to
overcome that either in kind of the
sensor space or utility or with clean
technology in particular I could see
that being an impediment yeah I think
for us in California I mean our
utilities were also precluded from
getting into the charging infrastructure
game and so they had to go in front of
the Public Utility Commission they had
to make their case SD Jeanie was just
approved last year to install 3500
charging stations within our region it's
part of their power your drive program
they're doing it interestingly and
they are trying to incentivize drivers
to charge when we have a lot of Sun we
produce a lot of solo at more solar
rooftop installations than any other
city in the country we've got to do
something with all that power during the
day and the utility through their power
your DRI program is trying to
incentivize drivers to plug-in during
the day when we have an abundant amount
of solar resources but again getting the
approval to do that was a lengthy
process a costly process and in really
an ongoing process so there is that
regulator the regulatory challenge I
think everyone faces but just to touch
on if we're gonna talk kind of the dirty
stuff here you know I represent my
organization clean tech San Diego
represents about a hundred and twenty
companies or members most of which are
private sector companies those private
sector companies trying to work within
the boundaries of the university or the
city or the utility is quite challenging
the the universities the cities the
utilities have created very large
bureaucracies that are very challenging
for the private sector to work within so
that so I think that's a you know that's
not a regulatory thing it's a it's a
process II that that we need to real you
know we need to figure out if we're
going to really propel adoption of
technology a lot of these kind of
bureaucracies are not allowing for it
and that's something that we we have to
turn upside down in order to move this
forward I mean on that bureaucracy front
so we live in a time of incredible
opportunity for change this new
technology and what we can do it all all
this data and is is is amazing there are
lots of places for us to focus our
attention one of the things that is so
special about being in this room with
all of you is is that the level of
collaboration in in in Pittsburgh and
and with Carnegie Mellon and as a
community that you have because you are
rebuilding and because you are focused
is a bet that we as a private company
make on and taking a look around the
room to say are these people
collaborating effectively is it likely
that there's going to be a positive
outcome and you have something very
special here and I think really making
sure that you continue that forward
movement with
you know palpable progress is the thing
that is necessary to for companies that
are figuring out where my best Jason's
doing an amazing job in San Diego it's
it's easy to be in San Diego because of
the this very effective organizations
have been put together it's great to be
here because of the level of
collaboration so I the dirty secret from
our point of view is there's a limited
amount of bandwidth and you got to
figure out where you're gonna make your
investments and and I wouldn't encourage
you because this is a great place rich
maybe do you I mean on that with with
collaboration you guys have some really
key projects in the Duquesne Light
Service territory both in terms of smart
meters and micro grids I mean and you
guys have been partners on some of those
two with Itron I mean what what kind of
leads to that from your standpoint and
your perch is the CEO of Duquesne Light
in terms of making those decisions on
which projects to advance versus where
do I hold my gunpowder
yeah so we're trying to approach it
taking a what I would call a varied
portfolio approach so as we talked a
little bit about earlier there's some
regulatory constraints to go through
trying to get regulatory approval for
something that's new and evolving is a
very long process it involves a lot of
intervenors coming in that want to carve
out their space so one of the things
that we've done and we're approaching it
from the perspective of developing pilot
programs so we have an AV charging pilot
program that we're doing we have a micro
grid pilot program that we're doing them
when you approach it from a pilot
perspective it's not as fast as you
would like it to go but what you're
doing is you're teasing out you know all
of the other stakeholder interests and
where they may be coming from you're
teasing out regulatory challenges that
may be there you're teasing out the
technology challenges that may be there
so that you can kind of do a
proof-of-concept
and then accelerate through the process
and hopefully win broad stakeholder
support when you go in to ask for that
regulatory change other things that we
do you know we partner with the other
utilities in Pennsylvania you know we
all kind of have a kindred spirit of how
we view the industry and our vision of
where it's going so together you know
it's the voice of many so to speak where
we try to get legislation introduced a
knock down you know some of the barriers
that are there you know we talked about
some of the regulatory impediments you
know and we talked a bit about gee I
think grant you were indicating you
don't need to replicate the
infrastructure two and three times right
so you heard and talked a little bit
earlier about the utility model the way
the utilities earn a return is you put
plant in the ground you earn a return on
that investment at the end of the day
well when you think about it you know
when we talk about smart cities and
smart meters that are out there Duquesne
Light is deploying you know a
state-of-the-art communication backbone
that the gather all of that data from
the smart meters that are out there
really doesn't make a lot of sense for
the water company to develop the same
Network the gas utility developed the
same network using one network you can
kind of leverage that investment once
because we're all serving the same
stakeholders right but when you look at
other utilities under that motto it's
gee well if I buy that service from
Duquesne Light I can't earn a return on
it so there's ways to overcome that we'd
have to go to the regulator and say look
just because we're buying a service from
a utility they should be allowed to earn
some type of synthetic return on that
right this way we're getting a much more
efficient you know deployment you know
of capital so I think those programs
kind of you know tease some of those
things out and it's it's going to be a
slower process then you would like when
you're involved you know with the
regulated industry part of its
bureaucracy as you indicated and I think
we're working hard to knock all of that
down we certainly are Duquesne Light but
the regulatory process really we need an
increased focus on a part of our
regulators to kind of up their game a
bit and you know start being
streamlining the processes so to speak
but as we know there's a lot of process
involved you know in that suit so maybe
to build on that a little bit and David
I'm gonna pivot to you here's you know
so regulations are put in place for a
reason right you know so that you're
trying to protect or or provide some
sort of continuity within a system and
one of the things that we talked about
earlier is these ideas of challenges you
know what are some of the challenges
that you guys see in your organization's
in terms of you know what's up ahead
what would kind of you know what are you
worrying about whether it's like cyber
threat or privacy data privacy issues
and
and how are you starting to organize or
marshal resources within your
organization's to kind of prepare
yourself for some of these these
challenges that lay on the horizon
solution first and I think rich said in
an others as well that this whole notion
of outreach and education or let me say
it differently collaboration so one of
the things that Edison Electric
Institute has been doing over the last
ten years is pulling regulators together
with utility executives such as rich
putting them in a room and dealing with
some very tough issues and it's an
off-the-record conversation we have
members of the financial community there
too and we deal with these cutting-edge
issues so that the regulator's get an
understanding of how their regulations
can be an impediment to the evolution
and the adoption of technologies that
has worked but as rich said that is a
very very very slow process because
there are hundreds of regulators
throughout the United States
you can pull ten regulators in if you if
you multiply that it would take you a
hundred years so there's got to be a
better process so the regulator's get
together three major times a year so
what we've tried to do at E is to have a
session with them a Saturday session
they get into town early we spring for
lunch and have a dialogue when some of
these big big issues let me tell you
what some of the big issues are and you
really started with one of them
cybersecurity
so as we digitize the electric system
that's really what we're doing we're
making that electric system much smarter
much more accessible much more customer
driven it means that there's a lot of
information that is provided to the
utility and utility is the trusted
adviser with the customer utility
through that smart meter with ami has a
lot of information they see but now
there are a lot of other technologies
that are plugging into that grid a rich
mention it one essential platform aside
from a from a communication plan
form is the grid all of these
technologies feed into that grid and
that grid is being modernized it's being
upgraded it's being digitized so as you
seek to do that and you have all these
different devices all these different
devices
raise your cybersecurity risk
see at the transmission level there are
mandatory enforceable rules at the
distribution level they're not I'm not
advocating that you need them but I'm
just suggesting that there is an
increased risk that now begins to be
exposure to the utility utility wants to
be way out in front and wants to serve
the customer wants to customize the
services once you use the best
technology thing they can't can to deal
with resiliency and reliability and
affordability but they also acknowledge
that as they do that they're enhancing
their cybersecurity risk so there needs
to be some would say best practices
there's needs to be this recognition
that we need to deal with this evolving
challenge is this challenge bigger than
the adoption of the technologies I don't
know because we I'm not going to say no
system is perfect so that's one risk but
there's a second set of risks that are
there technology risk rich mentioned
that he said we don't necessarily take
on the technology risk with one gulp
what we do is we do pilots so there are
a lot of technology risks that are
associated with what we're talking about
and what the utility seeks to try to do
is share those risks with someone else
and the regulator doesn't understand
that because we have a cost-plus model
we make an investment we get a return on
it
our pricing models got to change we've
got to incent behavior if you the
earlier panel spoke about charging
stations and the concentration of those
charging stations at the time where they
increase the demand on those substations
it means that you may have to increase
the capacity or you have to use a
different
for pricing structure and so we have to
make regulation understand that a
different pricing regime is very very
important but as they're moving to that
different pricing regime if I make it
too executive if I'm rich I want to make
sure I get my allowed return rich isn't
gonna want to put his return at stake
for an experiment on pricing so those
are the kinds of things that we have to
deal with rich want to go to you on this
I'm gonna go into some of the audience
questions here I get this nifty little
tool that they gave me so I'm gonna take
advantage of it you know this is from a
consumer standpoint data itself doesn't
seem to be usage data it doesn't seem to
be risky but I've been picking up maybe
with some of the things that Dave are
saying like how do you guys look at
systemic risk it's a real windy day out
there today we know Duquesne lights
working hard the lights are on right now
things are great but that's not always
the case when you're dealing with
natural born threats or others I mean
can you talk a little bit about how you
guys are working too hard in the system
and kind of reduce some of these risks
sure so there's a lot of things that are
going on so you have kind of the
physical risk to the system and then you
have the cyber risk to the system so
physically you know things that we're
doing there's a number of things we do
to harden the system the harden our
substation so that could be the
infrastructure around the substation to
protect it from somebody trying to do a
bad thing to the substation we take a
look at the infrastructure of the how we
design our grid so that we have
redundancy built into the grid we have
two-way flows so to speak that we don't
have any radial feeds or we minimize the
radio feeds that are out there we have a
lot of technology that we deployed I
mentioned earlier we have thousands of
sensors in the field those are
controlled through our SCADA system in
our control room so a good example of
that is a lot of times when you see an
adage you may see your power go out for
a minute or so and then it comes back on
that's our control room that's looking
out there and seeing through the
technology we have where is that fault
located and then they're isolating the
system remotely so that a good example
that would be 30,000 customers are out
but we
a Fault in one location they know where
they can isolate it from the rest of the
system bring the power back up within
minutes and now you've taken 30,000
customers down to within a minute down
to 5,000 customers are out ultimately
you have to roll a vehicle out there to
repair you know the woods out there but
that allows us really is significantly
you know reduce the outage time that's
out there so there's a number of
investments that we're making on the
asset side on the physical side and then
on a technology side on the cyber side
there's just a ton of investment that's
going on and partnerships with the AI
and other utilities the sharing of best
practices our operational system that's
out there that actually operates the
assets in the field and the technology
and a field is isolated from the outside
world so it doesn't connect to anything
else other than into our control room so
we isolate it that way as you start
looking at the proliferation of smart
meters and then the customer data and
things that come out of that we have to
look at that a bit differently because
there's desires for people to access
some of that information so when you
think about cyber security you know you
approach that from a number of different
ways you have multiple layers of Defense
for people trying to penetrate you you
kind of design your system like you
compartmentalize it like a ship right if
you have a rupture on the ship you close
doors inside it you isolate it so that
the ship doesn't go down we look at how
do we isolate and compartmentalize
different systems within the company
itself and then on top of that we need
to start thinking about from a cyber
perspective as we look at smart cities I
think that has to be approached by the
specific technology their specific
desires we need to do with that
technology in the field for example you
know when we take a look at deploying
all these sensors out there if that data
is coming in and we want to give people
access to it but they can't control or
do anything with it that's one layer of
security that you'll put around it if
you have control of it where you can
actually go out there and take that data
look at where traffic flows are now go
out and start switching traffic lights
and changing the sequence of it
that's a different level of control and
protection that has to go around that so
I think it's you know as you look at it
you want to try to compartmentalize it
and then apply the appropriate level of
risk mitigation in each of those
areas you know Jason and Philip I mean
you're seeing it with kind of new
startup companies developing new
technologies
I tried obviously been an established
company for a long time how how are you
guys looking at it both from kind of a
macro perspective but also are you doing
education with new companies who are
just creating the new whiz-bang gadget
in the clean tech sector what's the both
sides of that spectrum look like so
clean tech San Diego launched the San
Diego regional energy innovation network
last year which is a California Energy
Commission acronym today there is
there's which is a California Energy
Commission funded program to support
early-stage energy entrepreneurs and
help them get their product to market
the state of California is also set
aside about forty five million dollars
to invest in these companies so if you
have a start-up and you want to bring it
to San Diego let me know but what we've
done with that that that program and
probably the the biggest and most
important thing we've done is we've
brought the universe or that you know
the utility to the table we brought the
military to the table we brought these
different entities to the table that
these companies are trying to help solve
their issues so they can hear firsthand
from SD GE these are some of our
internal and external threats that we're
trying to face from an energy management
perspective or a distribution
perspective they can hear from the
military and talk about micro grids and
energy independence and what that means
and how their technology may be able to
fit into that so what we've done you
know we like pilot programs and pilot
projects in San Diego as well but you
know going back to this kind of notion
of collaboration when early-stage
companies can sit in a room and kind of
a neutral space with the utility with
the universities and others to talk
about their technology and kind of the
real-world application of that
technology there's significant benefit
in that and so I think these these types
of conversations not just happening here
on a stage but in a room with kind of
the next round of innovators is
increasingly important and we're using
those that ability to facilitate those
conversations and help in these
technology companies develop a
technology that actually has a market
and that market being around cyber
energy generation energy management
whatever it may be
yeah it's like maybe I agree
all these comments but a slightly
different take which is that we feel
that we're on the issue security and
privacy actually better off supporting
industry standards and and not trying to
go it alone you know so you know we're
working with best minds and standards
bodies in order to establish a common
set of standards and ask our partners
and startups to conform to a series of
privacy and cyber security and
communications and other standards we
need to make innovation easy and
predictable in order to really stimulate
it and so there when we talk about
platforms the rules have to be published
and then you have to have third parties
that can verify that the rules are being
enforced and so we have a number of
members in the audience from do he is an
example we've worked with the defense
labs on doing penetration analysis on
standards that we've used we're using
standard technology building blocks that
have been proven in other industries
financial markets as an example that
have very high security requirements in
which we're able to embed proven
technology and some new sensor
applications but but this stuff has been
around for a long time so that we're
leveraging huge technology investments
local example Qualcomm in San Diego
you know spends billions of dollars a
year on Rd when we have cellular
technology requirements we're gonna
we're going to draft off of the
investments that they've made so we're
collaborating on technology driving
standards and and using industry experts
in order to ensure that things have gone
properly thank you so there's this slide
of things starting to look like my email
feed so you guys are percolating a lot
of questions out there so I'm gonna make
sure that get to some of them here you
know in a you know one of the questions
from the audience here is about data
awareness and maybe picking up with
something Jason was saying here at the
Scott Institute in Carnegie Mellon you
guys are really building kind of the
pipeline of the next generation of
innovators that are gonna you know work
in companies like Duquesne Light and
clean tech San Diego and EEI and hITRON
can you talk a little bit about kind of
the role of the Institute intern
of kind of formulating this net
generation and not just tackling these
big issues but really creating the
technicians they're gonna fill in kind
of the the mindsets and and build this
next generation of applications so the
good news is that we have about a
hundred and fifty faculty that are
working in energy related topics already
and many of those are collaborating and
that's one of the things that we're
known at for here at CMU is the level of
sort of integration and collaboration
between our different colleges so when
people come to us and they have a
particular problem we actually are able
to pull the researchers together to sort
of tackle issues we've done that a long
time particularly with the Metro 21 and
the deployment sort of the way that
they've handled that and the Scott
Institute is sort of looking at some of
those things as well it's like how can
we be preparing because we know even
based on what Anne said this morning you
know it's certainly not the the utility
of the past the the skill set needs to
be entirely different and so the fact
that we're strong in robotics and AI
machine learning and cyber is an
incredibly strong asset for a university
like this one so what I like the most
about having all of you here and thank
you again for coming to campus is the
opportunity to hear you say those words
because as much as we say that on a you
know day to day basis or within a class
or you know within our daily work out in
the community it's an important thing to
hear from you all that that's what
you're really looking for can I just one
super quick thing grant sorry to break
this paradigm that suggested that there
are sensors that communicate that you
collect that information and then you
analyze it afterwards smart sensors are
probably going to be the future we're
talking about the next generation we
have to embed the intelligence out at
the edge of the network and have these
devices talking to each other we are not
going to control this new dynamic
volatile environment with one central
brain we're not going to Jay's insoles
model is broken down on the generation
side central computing is broken down as
a way to control this network that's got
these dynamic generation devices on it
so by please think outside the box in
terms of the paradigm that you're using
in thinking about next generation
devices that that that they are smart
communicative safe and secure
economical and last a long time by the
way it's not an easy thing to build but
more intelligent interoperable all of
those things it's AI that's what's gonna
drive everything you can look at all the
improvements a lot of improvements have
been made in hardware technology the
next level of improvements are in
software technology believe me
tremendous improvements that are taking
place so so I got time for two more
questions here real quick you know the
one thing here you know one of the folks
in the audience was asking beyond pilots
where some of the best strategies to
deploy technology you know this really
makes me think about some of the
challenges that we've seen in the city
is that we can get the pilots up and
running the challenge we have is going
to scale so what are some things that
you would kind of land in a conversation
maybe in you know a quick minute or so
in terms of how do you get the scale how
do we go beyond just the pilots so I
would say from the city of San Diego
perspective again going back to the
pilot that was a pilot with the street
lights in the sensors the city IQ
project that started as a pilot we're in
year 3 now and it's a full-scale project
I think the value of it's about 43
million so it started as a pilot and it
actually became something real I don't
know that that necessarily happens all
the time but I think what got it to
where it was to where it is today is
leadership from the city and a focus of
the city to get it to where it is today
but also the ability of and the
willingness of the private sector
company in this case current by GE to
work with the city to make sure that the
technology not only met the needs of the
city but also met the needs of their own
needs so I think it takes a champion on
both ends to push it to the end and
really see it be built to the extent
that it should be as opposed to just
remaining a small pilot program with a
few learnings I agree with them it's
public policy leadership and we can give
one good example and I'm not an advocate
for saying you have to have mandatory
renewable portfolio standards but it
took a few regulators I might be but I
can't say that it took a few regulators
to say we need to move increasing
towards renewables you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna mandate it okay so
that was public policy leadership
okay it takes public policy leadership
and then on the other side it takes
someone with deep pockets so if you're
trying to move a technology forward very
rapidly you need to Bill Gates or
someone else that believes in that
technology is willing to take the risk
put up $2 and someone who also has very
significant political persuasion so I
got I go I got the the hook here but I
got one more question I think my mom was
in the audience actually is the question
is how can energy utilities become
better partners with municipalities who
are working decrease sustainability and
resilience ie provide accessible data
and streetlights so I don't see my mom
but you know I mean we've had a great
relationship with Duquesne light but I
mean across the board and where do you
see kind of where do these relationships
taking us in terms of the partnerships
between universities and utilities and
cities what's what's the blue sky look
for you ten seconds and seconds economic
vitality focus on the outcome don't get
hung up on the mechanics of how it's
going to happen when we come together to
build more sustainable livable and
successful cities it will knock down the
barriers that stand in the way of our
collaboration terrific I don't know that
I have anything else to add to that it's
perfect his bio is visionary that was
perfect Anna so I would just say that
that research and and partnerships with
you two universities can be a big part
of that so we look forward to continued
conversation and we welcome the folks in
the audience to be a part of that too
Thanks thanks everyone thank you so much
this panel
you
go for the middle
we need to wait for a signal or am i
okay to start good afternoon everyone
I'm here to introduce this afternoon's
panel which is leveraging distributed
energy resources micro grids and storage
for city resilience quite a large topic
but I'm sure that old our panelists stay
will tackle it we have on our panel
today Ron get avec who is the founder
and CEO of wind stacks we have Ben
Morris who's the director of operations
work management and performance for
Duquesne Light Company we have Chris
Murray the senior Business Development
Manager for wgl energy we have Lydia sue
korok who is the director of strategy
and marketing from Siemens we have our
board owesome ovitch who is here as a
senior consultant from West Monroe
partners we have Romney Winstead who is
here for development engineering from
NRG and of course we have dr. J apt who
is going to be moderating the panel as a
professor from Carnegie Mellon so
without further ado we shall let them
kick off well thank you very much it's
it's a pleasure to be introduced so
expertly so first I'm going to give the
audience because we like a
intellectually diverse audience some
definitions distributed energy resources
so de ours is the specialists call them
D R is a term that refers to both
hardware and software connected to the
local electric distribution network and
so those resources can produce power
think of rooftop solar arrays or they
can consume power in a controllable way
think of an air conditioner whose
setpoint can be changed or a freezer at
Giant Eagle here in Pittsburgh where
they could be electric storage like a
tesla powerwall microgrids so a micro
grid is a small group of generators and
users of electricity loads as we call
them that are capable of supplying power
to the users within a defined area
and it can be connected to the grid or
operated on its own so those are the
definitions now everybody it's more or
less on the same page what I'm going to
do is ask some questions of the
panelists and then you folks have a way
to put in your questions I've got an
iPad here that those will come up on so
first question to Ben Morris and to
Chris Murray what distributed energy
resources are you seeing now on the
civilian grid Benford do king light and
at a u.s. Navy installation for Chris
Murray so Ben first in that dress I'm
happy to go first thank you Chris so for
Duquesne Light Company Duquesne Light is
the local electric utility serving
Pittsburgh and the surrounding area to
give you a sense of the size of the
electricity flowing across our system
our peak load was approximately 3
gigawatts or 3,000 megawatts which was
in June of 2012 so that was a
particularly hot year now if that's the
peak when we think about de are the de
are that we currently have
interconnected to our system is
approximately 18 megawatts so that's
approximately 0.6 percent of the of our
peak electricity that's still relatively
small but what what comprises that that
point six percent of our of our
electrical Rupert essentially is
primarily that the largest de ours is
solar so we have a handful and I mean
literally a handful of larger CHP
installations from different customers
on our system but by far that of those
18 megawatts it's primarily solar today
and the driver behind that is we need to
look back a few years historically but
in about 2010 that there was essentially
no de are in a system or no no
renewables in 2014 there there were
approximately three megawatts and a
hundreds of 200 customers with with with
solar or renewables 2016 the beginning
of the year approximately 5 megawatts
and
excellently 300 customers in the past
two years since 2016 we have grown from
five megawatts to approximately 18
megawatts and from approximately 300
customers to 2100 customers but that's
in two years that's big growth in in
what we're seeing for de are and the
drivers for that it's actually quite
easy to put your finger on in in 2016 we
had some some national entrants for for
solar developers in particular come to
Pittsburgh and begin marketing here so
those those national level marketers are
really the biggest drivers in the past
few years of the growth that we've seen
in the ER in Pittsburgh um specifically
I think there are two reasons why why
they've they've developed such growth
one is simply because they've done
door-to-door aggressive marketing so one
is just education and knowledge for
customers in the area the second and and
I suspect this is the bigger driver is
that the national lever level solar
developers have financing options for
for their product which before 2016
weren't available in Pittsburgh so in my
opinion it's it's both both the
marketing but probably more likely the
financing options that have driven the
growth that we've seen in the past years
so it's it's still relatively small in
the grand scheme of the electricity
flowing across our system less than 1%
but but the growth is is real and thank
you very much Chris hi Chris Murray WGL
Energy reason I got the question for the
Navy is prior to coming to wgl I spent
about two years at the Navy helping
build the student generation resources
for the Navy for resiliency purposes so
I'm gonna give you two answers to your
question what kinds of D ers does the
Navy like they like resilient dr's but
the more precise answer I'm also going
to give you two answers there last
administration it was all about
renewables specifically solar PV that
was primarily driven by the tax credits
we were trying to move a gigawatt of
knuble solar pv primarily as quickly as
possible to try to take advantage of the
tax credits they got extended we got
more breathing room but that's what was
driving we had a smattering of solar a
smattering of storage a smattering of
fuel cells a smattering of other stuff
but it's primarily solar now going to my
second answer of my two-part answer in
this administration again it's all about
resiliency resiliency resiliency and
some of the services have decided to
define resiliency in terms of something
that can provide 14 days of backup power
so what that means in a very agna
technology agnostic ways they don't want
diesel gensets
they want on-site resources that can
last 14 days that leaves you with guess
it solar PV and other things like that
where you can have no supply chain
issues in the business world is called
the supply chain and in the military
it's called the kill chain they don't
want to have a kill chain they want to
have something on-site that you can deal
with so it's primarily going to be solar
and storage but CHP a little smattering
of that as well some fueling cells again
you have a gas issue but the key word is
resilience Chris that's great answer
thank you so for Romulan what sort of
technology mix do you see being
necessary in order for distributed
energy resources in micro grids to
increase customer reliability and grid
resiliency thanks Jay I really like this
question because it hits on three three
major aspects of micro grids you know
you talk about we're talking about
technology mix we're talking about
customer reliability and we're also
talking about grid resiliency for me
when when I was oh when I look at this
it starts with customer reliability you
start with who your customers are and
when you start thinking about customers
you're thinking about the residential
sector your and as you move up this
market ladder you're thinking about
commercial customers industrial
customers institutional segments that's
key and as you keep moving up this
ladder what you see is the need for
reliability keeps going up it
as a multiplier and the importance of
resiliency also starts increasing based
on the type of operations so I think at
the end of the day I think all of these
people are looking for reliable
resilient power but the but before we
talk about what that right technology
makes is I would say you have to take a
pause to save for your customer what are
the what are your risk factors what are
your requirements and then talk about
what are you some of your goals and a
lot of these customers are thinking
about being sustainable some some
economics might come into play in terms
of operational savings you might have
other operational metrics all of these
things ultimately in my mind is what
defines that right technology makes oh
so I mean a classic example would be if
you take a medical center that is that's
a hospital that has serving patients you
have a vivarium maybe or maybe a first
responder emergency site there they all
have the same high level need of
resilient reliable power but when you
drill down the risks associated with it
the actual requirements and the goals
that they have might vary so your
technology and you know there's one
consistent threat though between all of
them when you think about this and
that's the need for energy that is
available to them at all times so in my
mind when you say energy it's not just
electrical energy or it's not just
mechanical energy it's both you have to
consider both in tandem because when you
look at your customers what you see is
these are people who are using both
electrical energy and thermal energy and
for the longest time we've looked at
technology and we've looked at
electrical energy and we know that
aggregating multiple buildings
aggregating multiple loads opens up and
a diversifies our options with the type
of generation we can put that put
on-site we could you know you have
economies of scale coming into play you
have better flattened load profiles and
now if you take on yet another aspect
get the thermal loads of these systems
and layer that in now your options are
even larger now you can think of having
a combined heat and power system you can
think of district energy systems you can
then layer that on with PV potentially
so the technology options start
broadening as you start thinking of
energy not just as electrical energy but
it's electrical energy and thermal
energy and so then what happens is you
have this wide array of options now
available to you you can have solar you
can have energy storage you can have
combined hidden power you can have
thermal energy and all of this together
is what and the right technology makes
at the end of the day is what clearly
meets the requirements what clearly
provides a solution for the risks that
were identified what helps you get to
those targets ok thank you very much
this is for wrong the Pittsburgh Airport
is exploring self generation options to
avoid the kind of mess that Atlanta got
into last December what can you tell us
about where customers like the airport
are going to be in the near future sure
sure so as Jay mentioned back in
December of last year the Atlanta
Airport lost power for all of their
critical systems frankly and it really
sent a jolt through the entire
transportation industry on the East
Coast and you know speaking of
resiliency if you think some of these
navy bases are resilient the the these
modern airports today are have an
amazing electrical kind of system
backups to the utility grid not only
traditional generators but CHP and steam
etc and in fact it's really layer upon
layer upon layer yet this still happened
in Atlanta so just recently the
Pittsburgh Airport looked at considering
right now and are taking requests for
qualifications for self generation for
those of you in the Pittsburgh area you
probably recall a few years ago that the
airport agreed to fracking and leasing
on the airport property so they
certainly have an abundance of natural
gas out there to look at that so that's
you know you know that I'd like to kind
of introduce the notion of prosumers
which are really our target customers
who customers who are considering
producing storing and consuming their as
much energy as they can and still
working with the grid as either the
primary or a backup source of power us
we're in the wind industry so the past
24 hours has been a great couple days a
great day for our customers to say the
least but I'll give you a quick example
if you indulge me for a minute we have
one residential customer that's an
elderly couple that I happen to live
near the airport that lost their power
for about three hours last night they
happen to have one of our wind and solar
hybrid systems with storage and to them
losing power is is a matter of life and
death they are both on CPAP machines and
they need they need them to you know to
sleep at night etc and they're deathly
afraid of carbon monoxide from
generators as well so our system was
specifically designed to give them four
hours of backup it had if they lost
their power that's exactly what happened
last night we also had a commercial
customer in Virginia that they got sixty
some mile an hour winds they lost their
utility power just for a half an hour
but for a commercial business that can
be very expensive especially in the
trucking business so they're the storage
for them was designed to really help
bridge that gap and you know if these
systems are designed right as storage
costs become cheaper the these interplay
with the utilities very well and do
things that utilities frankly don't like
anyway like it's people trying to get
eliminated some of the peak demand and
demand charges and things like that
because be if there's excess solar for
example that's generated through the day
and it can be sent back to the grid etc
so that's that's the kind of thing I
think you're gonna see more and more the
presumption model and you know just to
kind of reinforce the previous group who
talked about how utilities are precluded
from storage in some regulatory
environments I frankly also agree that
that's ready for a regulatory overhaul
because folks like Duquesne Light who
are more progressive in embracing these
types of technologies even in pilots
would be excellent partners for these
businesses I don't think many of them
don't necessarily want to do this and
maybe a 7 10 15 year ROI isn't fantastic
for their balance sheets so I think if
there's a platform to help utilities you
know embrace storage that's that's a way
to go
thank you Ron that's great for euros
New York avoided a billion dollars worth
of grid investments in Brooklyn Queens
by turning to demand management and
local generation and they also want to
avoid problems like they hit after
Hurricane sandy when the next sandy
comes what can you tell us about New
York's reforming energy vision so
reforming the energy vision is sort of a
initiative that was started by Governor
Cuomo back in 2014 and the idea is that
we need to have a clean affordable and
resilient Network hurricane sandy came
in 2012 and really last left the whole
city and in half a day eastern seaboard
devastated in New York City the subways
were completely flooded
Dovie hospital had to be evacuated and
many others so what we're trying to do
in New York is figure out what kind of
solution can help offset the traditional
investment in distribution engineering
so in Brooklyn Queens specifically
Consolidated Edison the utility company
that is in charge of New York City and
metropolitan area they forecasted that
69 megawatts of power is needed in the
ten years time and obviously a
traditional way would be to put in
another transformer to put another
substation put new cables in line and
that is that 1 billion or 1.2 billion
dollar investment that would be needed
in traditional infrastructure now
majority of the folks here in the room
understand that the distribution as well
as transmission infrastructure is sized
for the hottest day of the hottest hour
of the hottest day in a year so majority
at the time that that infrastructure is
being unutilized so perhaps there is a
better way of instead of putting a new
substation in place a better way to
solve this issue and again hit on all
three points which is again clean
affordable and resilient so non wire
alternatives or non NWA's is how New
York is calling it or if if you ask
somebody else and Straight Outta Compton
and it would be non wireless solutions
instead of NWA
we're looking at all sorts of
distributed energy resources demand
response energy efficiency any kind of
way so we can just sort of decrease the
load and has perhaps not even built that
substation so that 1 billion dollars is
being offset it by 200 million dollars
worth of investment again in these clean
potentially renewable and distributed
energy resources that are being built
across Brooklyn and Queens neighborhoods
in in New York so it's not just content
that is doing that as a matter of fact
it's to reforming the energy vision all
utilities in New York State are mandated
to take a look at how NWA or mws can be
used instead of traditional
infrastructure so what you do instead of
a typical pilot project or a
demonstration project you take that
money that was already allocated within
the capital investment plan for that
substitution you take it out of that
plan and you spend that money wisely on
a non wire alternate and by the way we
don't know yet if these non wire
alternatives wouldn't be able to last as
long as a transformer which has what
4050 years
lifetime typically we don't know yet if
solar and storage can withstand that
many years but at least were we're sort
of deferring that need for capital and
investing for let's say ten years or
twenty years or however long this
technology can last on top of that we're
seeing that load that forecast might
change in that ten-year period and at
the end of that ten-year period we're
gonna do another benefit cost analysis
see if there's still a business case for
an or wire alternatives or perhaps we
will indeed have to invest a billion
dollars into building out the grid gee
that's well that's that's very
interesting new information indeed I
think for many of us
so for Lydia your company Siemens has
recently formed a joint venture with AES
to provide energy storage solutions what
can you tell us about the business case
that you folks see for energy storage in
the air future thanks Jay so probably
the main question really is addressing
the business case for affluence or
Siemens in AES energy coming together to
form this venture but it is largely
driven by the business cases of our
customers so I think it's important to
examine you know where where is the
market for storage out there to start
with right so the vast amount of storage
that has been deployed is being the
wholesale or the utility if you look we
would like to call a utility side
deployment the projects that are visible
the volume of the projects that a es
storage has deployed really was driven
by
contracts with utilities customers and
whether you look at the projects like
the Australian large-scale power plant
or the California one the great the
theme that emerges really is is the
flexibility and the versatility of what
storage can provide for those customers
and and when I say that and if you go to
a storage conference you'll hear very
colorful descriptions of you know
storage is the Swiss Army knife of the
electricity sector and it's like bacon
everything is better with storage right
so why is that right I mean it truly can
help utility defer and the investment it
can help provide the capability to
whether you need fast and flexible
generation either capacity or energy if
you're looking at ancillary services AES
is also now demonstrating digital
inertia for example for systems that
don't have a lot of rotating equipment
there you really can do anything and
everything but what has really been in
it to me kind of interesting and
important is to look at this investment
theme on the large scale the storage
deployment aside and and the theme that
emerges is that you can build a whole
lot really fast and that really matters
for for capital investment so that's one
side on the behind the metres side and I
when I think about this I I can't not
think about the global aspect of
deploying anything any technology that
we work with because we're a global
company and I work with with our
colleagues that are across the world
behind a meter the largest driver for a
long time was reducing demand charges
and US has only a handful of markets
where where that has worked really well
with CNI customers but if you look at UK
or any other market that has
multi-tiered and very large spread of
electricity prices you that is that is a
really quick return on investment and it
will be even quicker as the
is dropping when it comes to a lot of
the projects that were involved in they
are all hybrid projects there are very
few cases where you know there's
standalone storage application for a
number of reasons whether it's cost or
tax credit advantage but really it's
about what does it do right and I think
that for a long time the community
talked about revenue stacking so
different ways of utilizing storage and
electricity market I think we talked
about that less and less partly because
of the modes of using the battery and
when it needs to be available how to be
managed but also because storage is
dropping in price when I think about
solar contracts BPA's and when we had
you know inverter reserves years ago
because inverters were very very
expensive you know it's not an issue
anymore you can replace it very cheaply
we'll be able to do the same thing with
batteries now those who are selling to
the end-users of batteries what is their
business model going to be right of
course you can sell the batteries the
question of course is how do you make
money I think it's not a secret that
those who have very large pipeline of
projects are very competitive in the
market so the Tesla's and AES is of the
world or influence it now just the sheer
that the sheer control of the supply
chain is something that really matters
but that's really only one side of it
the other side of it is also how do we
package and how do we then control these
systems and so the theme that emerges
and that is not has been less of an
issue in large-scale projects but I
think in smaller scale projects is going
to be this overhead beyond the battery
price it's only one third of the system
costs right so if you follow the debate
and solar photovoltaics distributed
solar for a long time you know the soft
costs of implementing solar there's
going to be a whole lot of that and so
what are the advantages and what are the
solutions that can help you become more
competitive in smaller scale storage I
think are very endemic to the customer
and the mark
that you're addressing and and I could
talk about that for a week I'm really
really a long time but here's an example
of something where Siemens brought a
very unique advantage to fluence and and
because a es was not dealing with
storage other than very large scale
batteries in the utility segment is the
very fast startup of the batteries and
so we're talking about few milliseconds
that can really differentiate you know
the kind of backup that a certain
customer might need depending on
criticality of the power another theme
that emerges I think is also because the
technology has been dear risks at this
point and is also becoming cheaper more
commonplace the financing is a lot
easier so we're going to see third-party
ownership being being available and
certainly is available right now with
fluence as an example but that is also
going to be in the mixed with outright
ownership of the batteries for a very
long time so the management and the
de-risking of the operation of the
battery then is going to be a core
competency for the business that's its
financing it thank you so much that's
great
then Duquesne Light is proposing to
develop a pilot project micro grid at
your operation center on the North Shore
for resiliency and long-term outage
mitigation can you describe that project
a bit for us and also the regulatory and
legislative aspects that you folks need
to make that go absolutely Jay thank you
and and I think we'll actually tackle
the question in Reverse so maybe
starting with what we're trying to
accomplish at a bigger scale - so within
Pittsburgh that the our our customers
but also the local government are are
have a strong interest in resilience for
for their operations and and for their
activities so what what do cane light
company ultimately is attempting to do
is to move
or the implementation of micro grid
technology within the Greater Pittsburgh
area there are different ways that we
can do that and say well I'll share with
you what we're trying to accomplish an
app um to explain that I'm going to draw
one distinction which is a micro grid
which is behind the meter and serving a
single customer and a micro grid that
would be in front of the meter on the
greater utility grid and serving
multiple customers when we think about
Duquesne Light companies which run micro
grid project I'll explain that the
details of the project momentarily but
but I'd like to be clear that it's a
behind the meter micro grid on Duquesne
Light company's own property and the
purpose of that is is resilience
resilience of our own operations campus
which to describe the campus it's
approximately 18 acres seven buildings
it has our most critical operational
activities there from the operation of
the grid itself to the deployment of the
crews that would restore power to
downtown Pittsburgh if power to be lost
in an extended regional grid failure so
for for our projects and I'm actually
not going to describe it as a pilot
project J because it's it's on our own
property so do you Kane like company
like any other of our customers has the
right to install a micro grid behind the
meter on their own property yeah that's
what we're trying to do with the which
run micro grid um it's it's we're trying
to protect our campus in in order to
protect downtown Pittsburgh from a
prolonged outage before I get into
legislation I will pause to explain what
what our micro grid looks like so I
describe the campus itself 18 acres
seven buildings Duquesne Light company's
primary primary operational activities
um on that campus the way that we're
constructing our micro grid is
conceptually we have a distribution ring
that encircles the campus and goes to
each of those buildings and then in
terms of the ER
we currently have a
we have three diesel generation units
that are interconnected to individual
buildings that they are not currently
interconnected to a ring so they can't
serve all seven buildings so what we're
trying to do from a resilience
perspective is divert to diversify those
fuel sources I'm specifically what we're
doing is to install centralized natural
gas generation of 2.5 megawatts which is
sufficient to serve the whole campus um
which will add fuel diversity for the
diesel with diesel typically the fuel is
stored on-site for natural gas
generation it's brought in by pipelines
so it's fuel that's off-site presently
we're looking at a small amount of wind
resources but but we're not looking at
renewable generation in a big way yes
however we are designing the project so
it could be incorporated at a later date
so the one thing that I forgot to
mention so 2.5 megawatts of centralized
natural gas generation we also have an
equal amount of 2.5 megawatts of battery
energy storage systems and that size is
sufficient to carry the entire campuses
load for approximately 5 minutes that's
not long at all the sole purpose of
those couple of minutes is to smoothly
transition from having the campus green
grid connected I'm too isolating into
islanded mode so in a nutshell the micro
grid is 2.5 megawatts of natural gas
generation
I'm 2.5 megawatts of battery energy
storage for 5 minutes and a micro grid
controller to tie it all together so
that that's the project and again that
that's a regulatory project we're
seeking recovery of that through the
existing regulations on our own property
as a facilities project essentially
we're protecting our facilities just
like any of our other customers
now now looking forward where we'd like
to go and where our customers and and
the city would like us to go it is to
build micro grids on the broader
distribution grid where we can protect
multiple customers in critical areas
like the downtown Oakland hospital
district or
water treatment facilities critical
community infrastructure SS in order to
get there what we're attempting to you
with our pure utilities in Pennsylvania
is to introduce legislation at the state
level and specifically House bill 1412
which is a House bill that that's
proposing that utilities electric
utilities in the state can implement
utility owned micro grids in front of
the meter serving multiple customers so
currently that that House bill has been
voted out of the veterans and emergency
preparedness committee at the state
legislature level um it will go before
the broader legislature this year
hopefully and should it pass Duquesne
Light Company would then propose pilots
that are in front of the meter and more
in line with what the city and our
customers are looking for us to bring to
protect broader Pittsburgh it's it's
that's where we are perfect that's great
I really appreciate that
so for Chris I might ask you what do you
see as the economics of micro grids and
there's a question from the audience
closely related that says what's the
main roadblock to micro grid deployments
they're expensive what's the main road
block they're expensive I told you they
were closely related questions so
economics in there in an ideal world you
can make money you can save money you
can have increased resilience much might
have which might allow you to save money
which I'll explain and then it might
just look good for your branding and
marketing for sustainability purposes so
let me explain with regard to make money
Lidia already kind of mentioned it
sometimes if you have a micro grid that
has a battery and maybe it's connected
to solar or maybe it's connected to gas
whatever it's connected to it has
resources that you can use and as access
resources that you can bid into a
wholesale market so you still have
enough energy on-site to maintain
resiliency in sight but you have an
access that you can provide for instance
in PJM maybe fighting
frequency regulation that's a nice and
I've in the places I've worked actually
actually not peak shaving or peak demand
charges that are actually I'm not making
any money on that
it's ancillary services can help me
finance a project so that's the make
money part terms of the save money a
couple different things if I have solar
and maybe gas combined with a battery
behind the meter and I'm in a high
priced part of the country maybe I'm in
the Northeast I'm going to be able to
sell that commodity
to the end-use customer and a lot
cheaper rate than they are going to be
able to get it from the grid so instead
of paying twelve cents in New England
maybe they're only paying six cents from
the behind the meter so they're gonna
save on the commodity they're gonna save
also because maybe they have a big
operation on campus maybe they've got
lots of generation already built on
campus because they've got fancy stuff
for instance there's a campus in DC
fda's white oak campus they do a lot of
research there they can't let the
electricity go down they there's certain
things that probably shouldn't get
unfrozen diseases and other things so
they got to make sure that they have
absolute resilience at all times and
never go down they don't have a battery
on-site if I put a battery on-site I
might actually be able to optimize this
system so I don't have to do spinning
reserves I'm gonna save them money also
if I'm going to a corporate customer
they're thinking I gotta build a big
building I've got to build the walls and
the lighting and I've gotta build all
the boilers and chillers and I say wait
a second
you don't have to do the energy
infrastructure at all I can buy that I
can element operate it and maintain it
that 100 million dollars you're gonna
spend on that big campus maybe I can
shave off 10 percent of that maybe that
is my capex in my op X and then I'm
building that into the rate that they're
paying so maybe they can save money by
thinking about a micro grid differently
because they're not doing the capex op x
so resilience may be there our
manufacturing facility and if they have
a
or maybe sir research facility and they
have a little blip they have to throw
all that stuff away if it's Big Pharma
they're throwing those pills away if
it's a Navy research facility they're
taking literally research projects go
for two years straight get a little blip
if you got it
throw it in the trash and start all over
so a little bit of resilience he's gonna
save his staff time money and lost
product maybe you're a corporation and
you want to show that you have our green
the way you do it
typically in old school is let's buy
some racks let's show that we're doing
green energy well what if you had the
micro grid behind the meter maybe you
had solar behind the meter maybe you're
thinking about your sustainability play
and a lot broader way it's not just
buying recs but it's producing clean
renewable resilient energy behind the
meter and saving money in the bottom
line to help you then build your micro
grid so that is the business case in the
world world which I still have yet to
see and try that's great so um let me
incorporate one of the questions from
you folks in the question furrow Mia
during sandy the natural gas grid stayed
up in a lot of places not all places you
folks have a 1.4 megawatt fuel cell in
Bridgeport and you've also got a smaller
fuel cell pilot project coming in here
what can you tell us about those
projects at the University of Bridgeport
in Connecticut we have a 1.4 man
megawatt molten carbonate fuel cell
essentially it's a unit that in addition
to providing electrical power also
recovers heat it recovers about 2.2 mm
BTUs of hot water it's it's again it
comes down to the size of the system and
the load profiles that the university
sees this this fuel cell is able to
carry about 80 percent of the campus
loads the heat that's recovered gets
used as hot water in three of the
buildings that are on site so overall
the the sizing of the system worked
perfectly with the loads that were there
at the University now in addition to
that what we decided to do was
incorporate the loads that were existing
identify what the critical loads are
bring in a control of bringing controls
for load management and create a system
on-site create a distribution system
on-site that allows this unit to island
itself if it sees instability on the
grid so that's where I think
traditionally it's a base load operation
that runs 24/7 it helps the university
supplement some of its energy needs and
on the other hand if there is a critical
micellar disturbance or there are storms
or something passing through the season
it seamlessly transitions and Islands
itself and powers all of the critical
facilities so that was one area where we
started working with fuel cells and we
started at understanding what some of
its characteristics were and so we
extrapolated that into looking at other
kinds of fuel cell technologies molten
carbonate being one of them that we'd
seen solid oxide fuel cells were another
one we were interested in and so right
now we're piloting a 200 kilowatt much
smaller than the 1.4 megawatt unit out
at Bridge for just particular watts at
the North Shore NRG Energy Center right
here in Pittsburgh the idea here is that
we want to tie it to our existing plant
we generate steam and chilled water now
this would be a supplement to the and
another source of energy on-site and
essentially it's a five thousand our
pilot project which we're working with
fuel cell energy and Eva thank you very
much so I'm going to ask for one minute
answers for the next three questions if
I can
let me start with reject can you
describe how Siemens sees the
distributed energy resource landscape
evolving in the near future so there's a
I think the question actually probably
warrants
on Siemens the evolution of the system I
think that the trend actually of
digitalization of these resources is
incredibly important it is when we hear
and talk about and read about the energy
of the service including micro grid as a
service implementation when you actually
read what that is mostly talks about
financing micro grids but if we can
imagine being able to operate and manage
whether your utility that owns micro
grids behind or front of the meter or a
customer who doesn't want to have to
deal with having to optimize their
systems any number of things trying to
reduce RNN I mean that is also another
big driver that is an ability that is
going to be very very easily accessible
but it's not a routine offering in the
field quite yet
I have a few other thoughts but we have
only one minute so thank you so much
appreciate it
Oris we have seen some proposals for
deferring capacity like the
brooklyn-queens what projects that
involve capacity deferrals do you see
that have positive economics so that
really depends on the location again the
brooklyn-queens have made sense because
it was a 1.2 billion dollar traditional
investment if we're talking about
upstate New York or any rural area where
land is cheap and you can put a couple
extra poles and now there it's a
transformer in there it might not make
sense again what we've seen really work
very well is again energy storage
why because indeed can operate in a
wholesale market frequency response
voltage support and especially if it's
coupled with solar so it has access to
that investment tax credit and demand
for has to be charged by that solar at
least 75% of the
that really is a combination that we see
working in a lot of places well thank
you my iPad timer says we have one
minute so Ron can you tell us where you
see community silver going in one minute
no I cannot positive or negative yes
yeah you know just to use another quick
example we're working with a
post-traumatic stress syndrome veterans
retraining center in Arizona that is a
more or less an off-grid community that
they have a number of residences about
50 of them and they're learning skills
while they're going through
rehabilitation which include solar and
alternative energy wind sustainable
farming and other things so this is a
situation where we're putting in a high
voltage DC micro grid a one megawatt
battery storage system completely wind
and solar that happens to be off-grid
south of Las Vegas so we do get quite a
few inquiries about that so and in other
major users like indoor agriculture
we're seeing more and more of the
thoughts of not energy as a service but
energy as an investment which is a
different philosophy in our group well
thank you all very much and I hope that
the panelists have given you all an idea
of the breadth and really vibrance of de
ours and micro grids in the current
climate so please let's thank our
panelists
[Applause]